عشره عناصر عربيه في قائمه يونسكو جديده
للتراث الثقفي غير الماديه وهي فالغناء
الراي الجزائري كفن الاصيل يخص الجزائر
كذلك صنف حذاء الابل احد التعبير الشفهيه
في منطقه الخليج العربي خصوصا جزءا من
التراث غير المادي ومن مصر اخترت
الاحتفالات المتعلقه برحله العائله
المقدسه من بيت لحم الى مصر للقائمه
الجديده ومن الامارات صنف فن التطبيقات
التلي الاماراتي واحدا من التراث غير
المادي وسجل نخيل التمر العربي ايضا في
قائمه الامميه
العود السوري احد ابرز اصناف قائمه
اليونسكو الجديده كذلك المنسف الاردني
كوليمه احتفاليه شعبيه اردنيه واضيف
للقائمه ايضا الخنجر العماني المعروف
باستخدامه كازيه شعبيه في سلطنه عمان
والهريسه التونسيه المميزه وشهيره